[Musik]
hey leute ganz spontan das video wir
sind gerade total im burger fieber haben
die bürger bayerns gemacht die bürger
pettys und jetzt mache ich noch
karamellisierte zwiebeln und weil ich
weiß dass ganz viele von euch dann mal
im internet suchen die werden
karamellisierte zwiebeln gemacht möchte
ich das hier als kleines extra video und
ich bin jetzt auch schon hier direkt
bereit mit meinem kopf habt ihr
neutrales öl einmal erhitzen lassen auf
mittlerer bis mittel bzw stufe 96 sie
was ein bisschen einfacher habt ihr
erhitzen lassen und gibt er jetzt meine
zähne rein die habe ich ganz normal
halbiert und in dünne scheibchen
geschnitten und die werden bald eine
minute lang angedünstet
[Musik]
nachdem die zwiebeln dann richtig schön
glasig gedünstet sind geben wir zockerei
und noch eine prise salz und dann das
ganze auf mittlerer stufe richtig schön
karamellisieren lassen
[Musik]
nach 18 minuten sind die zwiebeln jetzt
richtig schön karamellisiert ich zeige
euch auch mal die farbe und jetzt würde
ich das nur noch oben und dann könnt ihr
das einfach genießen
[Musik]
also haben sie nicht essen das jetzt
zusammen mit unseren bürgern einfach
schön auch dass gleich geben ihr könnt
es aber auch ganz einfach mit brot essen
so als tipp das habe ich in marrakesch
und einem junggesellenabschied nämlich
auch das erste mal da so als tipp
gegessen und dachte mir eigentlich eine
ganz coole idee dass dazu zu reichen
also wenn ihr das ganze jetzt nach
machen möchte dann schaut hier unten in
die infobox das schreibe ich euch die
mengenangaben rein und dann könnte ganz
einfach eure karamellisierten zwiebeln
zu hause selber machen und ich freue
mich wenn ihr mal video ein dörfchen
nach oben gibt und ein kommentar
schreibt und dann sehen wir uns auch
beim nächsten lauf des kitsches
[Musik]